c'est encore en plein chantier mais
bientôt dans ce parking sous terrain
désaffecté de la cité des indes à
sartrouville
on y trouvera des salades des aromates
ou encore des fruits et des légumes
la start-up chant perché créée par deux
frères est en train d'installer une
ferme urbaine dans 1300 m² de sous sol
le fait d'être en parking et de manière
générale en intérieur et encore plus en
sous sol permet d'avoir et de bénéficier
en fait d'une isolation naturelle
on a une chape en dalles en béton très
épaisse et presque un mètre de terre au
dessus de nous ce qui permet d'avoir une
température beaucoup plus stable tout au
long de l'année
autre originalité le mode de culture la
ferme urbaine sera en bio pony une
technique de culture hors sol qui
mélange l'agriculture biologique
l'hydroponie et la permaculture
cela permet de produire à la verticale
700 m² seront dédiés aux plantations
l'équivalent d'un champ de 24 hectares
c'était vraiment essentiel même si on
fait la culture en intérieur sans terre
sans lumière naturelle de respecter les
principes de la permaculture et de la
biodiversité
donc on va essayer d'insérer le maximum
de vies dans ces espaces afin
d'atteindre un équilibre naturel comme
on aurait en extérieur en prêchant la
start-up champéry n'en est pas à son
coup d'essai une première ferme et des
jambes fonctionnement à paris ce qui a
permis de trouver de nouveaux
financements 2,2 millions d'euros pour
celle de sartrouville
on a déjà une trentaine de variétés
d'aromates plusieurs salade une
vingtaine de variétés de micro pousse et
le but ça va être de diversifier
beaucoup les fruits et légumes
le gros défi de cette ferme c'est
d'arriver à faire pousser des tomates
des melons et ce même au mois de
décembre
les travaux devraient se terminer d'ici
fin juin et les premières cultures
seront disponibles à la fin de l'été la
ferme urbaine vendra ses produits en
circuit court dans un rayon de 15 km
autour du parking souterrain